محمود لماذا تصبح الدبابه صيدا سهلا في
المدينه الدبابه احدى اهم الاسلحه البريه
وتستخدم في الجبهات وهي تحمي ايضا قوات
المشاه وتستخدم في الاقتحامات واستهداف
الاهداف عن بعد عبر مدفعها لكن للدبابه
ايضا زوايا عمياء وهي بحاجه قوات المشاه
لحمايتها من الاستهداف القريب ولذلك
احيانا ما تحيطها قوات المشاء او تتقدمها
بحسب ما يشير الخبراء الان عندما تدخل
دبابه وهي جسم كبير الى داخل المدن فانها
تكون محاطه بابنيه و كتل اسمنتيه كبيره
فبالتالي هذا يسهل للمهاجم الاقتراب منها
والاستفاده من الزوايا العمياء حتى لو
كانت الدبابه تمتلك كاميرات فان المسافه
التي يستطيع المهاجم الاقتراب منها تكون
صغيره
وبامكانه باغتت هذه الدبابه سواء من
الاعلى او من السطح او من الاسفل وبالتالي
تصعب عمل الدبابه وصعوبه حركتها بين هذه
الكتل وبالتالي الحرب بالنسبه للدبابه
داخل المدن اصعب بكثير من الجبهه